-Mark Grunting- Maximum Effort
-more grunting and panting-
OoOh God, in heck
-sigh of relief-
Hey
Hi
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
Boink! Chica hop on up here. Good girl
Hey! How's it going? Am I even in frame? I have no idea
I'm gonna assume "no". Stayyy
-Rumbles from camera- OOOooOh! OOOh
-More rumbles from camera moving-
Chica stay there! -continued rumbling-
Chica! -more rumbles while mark grumbles at chica- Nononono... Stay right there
Hi Chica! 'scooze me thats my spot
-strains from picking up Chica-
Okay, so, uh quick update, ummm
I finally have been able to get settled back in
I know i got back in town... Chica what are you doing... -giggles from mark-
-through giggles- Chica are you okay? ...okay.. chica you good?
Alright Chica's comfy.
Chica you're a cutie. you're a cutie patootie and I love you
Hi. hows it going. Now you may have noticed that the videos over the past week have been super sporadic.
Which is kinda weird considering I've been back in town for a full week.
But last week I was working on a lot of different projects, that don't actually have anything to do with videos
uh, and ALSO I was doing collabs with people
Uh, I can tell you about one of them, Rhett & Link, Im gonna be on good mythical morning, this Wednesday actually
We did some cool stuff there, and I did another collab recently that I don't know if I can talk about yet
and then I did one more, where I did some vocals for another random encounters musical
If you haven't seen it, it's the Five Nights at Freddy's stuff that we did
Five Nights at Freddy's the musical. The big like five part series that they created
So I've done a lot of stuff with them in the past, including like Resident Enis and things like that
But I've also, uh, we're working on the Cuphead musical, and I do a voice in that one
Now that ones not gonna come out for a couple months
Uh.. but it's just really cool because this year...
I have a tonne of new things that I wanna do. And a-ah-I always say that I want to do new things
But this year especially, I'm kinda committed to..
allowing myself to be in the right mindset. Not only to make whatever I wanna make but also
allowing myself not to get bogged down on the things that don't really matter
when it comes to making videos, because I've been doing this for about six years now
I've--y'know I've run the gambit of the emotions of like
'OOH THIS IS NEW AND EXCITING' to 'Oh I miss the old days!' to 'OH YOU'VE CHANGED MARKIPLIER HOW COULD YOU DO THIS TO US!'
Y'know I've run the gambit of all the different emotions.
And I'm to the point, and I said this last week, where I'm to the point where I'm in a really good space
I feel a lot happier about creating things.
And I feel a lot more comfortable, with experimenting about the types of things that I can do
So uhh. *giggle* It's gonna be, basically in my mind, what I've come up with is
This year is gonna be, 'the year of very weird videos'
because, on- one of th- one of the things that I always do is I'm always inconsistent
uh, in pretty much everything I do in life
I'm inconsistent to the point of ridicule.
I am ju--laugh- I am just so absolutely all over the place in everything that I do
That no one can really peg down, what to expect next
an- and that's something that I really wanna embrace this year, because
Last year was the uh, Last year was like the year of doing a lot of big team projects
Where I had, uh, all of us working on a date with markiplier, markiplier TV, who killed markiplier
Lotta big projects
This year, I wanna execute a lot of very small ideas very quickly
Because I feel this, I feel this urge, to like do, random bullshit all the time
I have this urge, and I may actually do it
Where I wanna do a 24 hour livestream
That's not for charity. It's just, for me to try to learn a skill in 24 hours.
and livestream the whole process
and just get the emotional gambit of, starting it, knowing failure, failing more, getting desperate, losing all hope
and then at the end, like in the twenty third hour, actually making some progress at the skill
and I have no idea how it's gonna go
or even if I can do it, but it's just.. y'know
i-it's just gonna be a lot of fun... this year.
i-I think anyway
Y'know I've been doing this for so long, that you guys have been with me for this wild ride where..
It's been both an emotional journey and also a ridiculous journey when you really think about it in the whole aspect of what I've been doing
But.. I never want to stop making new things
I- I- I've said it before but I run exclusively on "Fuck You" Energy™
Where, if someone tells me that I can't do something
I will go out of my way, to make sure I can do that one thing. Or at least try my damnedest at that one thing
If someone tells me that I can't.. I print out a picture of their face and I punch it repeatedly
and then do that thing that they said I couldn't do
I operate under the premise that, I don't know what I can't do.
But no one else gets to define what I can't do except myself
And I'll never stop trying new things, until I find the one thing that makes me really excited
And then the next day that might be gone! And I'm on to something new
That's what this year is really gonna be about.
I wanna do more collabs, I wanna do more challenges, I wanna do more random bullshit
I wanna do more, like, going to weird places, to experience weird different things... You know
I wanna do, so much more.
and uh, yeah. I mean that's it. Thats pretty much it because its so easy for me to go like
I have this grand sweeping thing! and THIS IS THE WAY THINGS ARE GONNA BE NOW.
but thats now what it's about, y'know
That's never been what it's about.
It's not about me, like trying to reach this new pinnacle of greatness.
Its' just about me, everyday, waking up, and being like what do I want to make today
What do I want to create today? What do I want to try to do today
And so long as I can approach every single day with that mindset, I'll always know that I'm moving forward in life.
I'll always know that I'm conquering the blockades that I put up in my mind.
I'll always know that I don't have to be chained down to any one core concept
Because, if you allow yourself to become chained up to one thing, then y-you get this...
in the.. like... numbing fear of losing everything... y'know
You become chained to these obligations that you don't really have, but in the end, those don't matter
All that matters is, do you feel like you accomplished something new today.
Do you feel like you chipped away at a big project today. Do you feel like you've moved forward in your life, today
Plan for the future and reach for the goals you have. But also just tackle each day as it comes
And thats what I want to do this year. I don't wanna really have grand sweeping plans this year.
I don't have any huge goals that I have. I'm already a big Youtuber. I could be a bigger Youtuber someday
But, all I know is that today I want to create something different than I wanted to create yesterday.
And so long as I chase that feeling, like I'll always be making new stuff, and I'll always be surprising you with what I can make
And uh, It may be inconsistent, it may be consistent sometimes. It may be, a series that I'm doing now
It may be a van vlog that I'm doing later. But,
it's all gonna be fun
And it's all gonna be worth it in the end, because...
I'll know that I'm improving
and that's all I can really hope for
-much more upbeat- So anyway!! I just wanted to quickly catch you up on everything. I've got other stuff I'm gonna be working on today
I've got other ideas I'm gonna be executing soon. And it's just gonna be a lot of fun.
So thank you everybody so much for watching, thank you for being here with me.
And as always, I will see you in the next video.
BUH BYEEE!!!
aaAaaaAAAHH'kayBYE UAHAHAgaAAHaAgHH!!
(Mark tripping and falling) Oah! Fuck I fell....
Hi... Bye...
...Ow...